la voie est libre de suite merci retour
sur le plateau de la voie est libre où
nous parlons de la politique régionale
en matière de transport avec nos quatre
invités jury oui sur ce plateau
débattent en direct depuis 11 heures
michel neugnot le premier vice président
socialiste du conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté en charge des
transports à vos côté gérald gordat
conseiller régional les république a
également sur ce plateau un autre
représentant d'un groupe d'opposition au
conseil régional damien quand un
conseiller régional front national et un
représentant de la fnh note la
fédération nationale des associations
d'usagers des transports le président
bourguignon
cédric joue rebonds et les
téléspectateurs bourguignons ont vu dans
leurs flashs régional qu'il ya encore
deux morts un sur la rcea cette nuit la
route centre europe atlantique
le conseil régional cofinançant les
travaux sur cette route comme elle le
fait sur la rn57 par exemple en franche
comté où la rn19 qu'est ce qu'on attend
pour faire deux fois deux voies est ce
qu'on ne peut pas accélérer les travaux
nous demande vanesse notamment si je
remarque quand même qu'il ya eu une
politique volontariste
entre 2004 et 2015 et long avec françois
patriat oui c'est long on aurait voulu
aller beaucoup plus vite on était en
rendez vous ensuite il ya eu un travail
avec la le département de saône et loire
avec la 6ème avec les élus locaux
manière sombre ou pour mettre le paquet
là encore dans le budget pour ne pas
perdre de temps nous allons anticiper
une partie du financement d'état pour
que ça se réalise au plus vite
c'est la région la plus accidentogène
vous savez que c'est un débat politique
que nous avions avec une partie de notre
majorité
mais nous avons toujours tenu bon et
nice en priorité on ne peut pas tolérer
ces accidents à répétition et un hydre
et des indices mais a très vite et je le
modèle qui a été trouvé avec la volonté
des élus partagés de saône-et-loire cire
de ne pas être en concession autoritaire
mais de portée eh bien il ya plus de 500
millions de travaux qui sont en cours
qui sont financés et qui doivent
permettre j'espère le plus rapidement
possible de répondre
allez un petit mot chacun sur cette
question damien de voir aux informations
des accidents mortels sur 7 sur fait
tout sur la rcea 2004 2015 pour le
mentionnions oui mais je pense qu'il
faut vraiment accéléré c'est un intérêt
général pour tout le monde on a peur de
prendre cette route aujourd'hui et je
pense que la région peut vraiment
participer à cette mise en sécurité
c'est route avec deux fois deux voies
est en relation avec l'état mais il faut
faire quelque chose aujourd'hui et plus
attendre encore 10 ans 15 ans la vie
d'un autre élu de ces pratiques et ce
matin encore venir ici je la pratique
est dans quelques instants pour rentrer
chez moi je connais très bien le dossier
je connais très bien cette route
vous avez peur prendre l'air ça je me
pose même plus la question à vrai dire
mais la question le problème de fond
c'est que ça ne passait vite et monsieur
venu nous disions bombers ont fait au
maximum au niveau des volontaires et
nous disent il ya trois ou quatre ans un
certain arnaud montebourg nous annonçait
qu'en 2017 la coupe la route serait en
totalité à deux fois deux voies entre
chalon et paray-le-monial et entre mâcon
et paray le monial et ça c'est
inadmissible d'aujourd'hui entre en
termes de crédit était la parole
publique ce n'est pas acceptable
et aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faudra
qu'on accélère encore plus et il faudra
surtout qu'on se préoccupe des 30 km qui
sont même pas envisagées après 2025
parce qu'aujourd'hui on nous dit on fait
au maximum n'empêche que c'est pas pour
faire 100 millions de gourdes ce que les
gens veulent voir c'est la réalisation
et la réalisation elle n'est même pas
envisagées en totalité d'ici 2030 un nom
qu'il faut vraiment vraiment un vrai
sujet encore il faut cédric jeauneau ça
doit être une priorité on sait que c'est
à d'autres chantiers alors là il ya des
bourguignons sur ce plateau mais par
exemple
en franche comté la mise à deux fois
deux voies de la rn 57 qu'un axe
nord-sud qui passe par vesoul et
besançon guette encore un widget encore
mais reste beaucoup par exemple afin
disent aussi mais qui sont prévues ces
deux leviers zoos côtes raides plan et
qui on est très vigilants pour que la
parole donnée par l'état sur ses 57 dans
sa partie lorraine hallé déjà deux fois
deux voies depuis plusieurs années alors
qu'en france il ya eu par l'ansa
traînons il ya une décision en 2013 2014
avec le département de haute saône qui
porte
ces travaux d'accélération et c'est en
cours on dit toujours ça traîne mais moi
je me retrouve quand même vers eux mes
amis les agneaux salaires à certains
journaux n'a pas pu accéder à la france
par rapport à la lorraine non mais je
vous dis que ya du retard mais qui est
rattrapée avec le bleu le plan d'urgence
qui a été fait par la région franche
comté dans la fin du précédent mandat et
d'autre part majoré mettre tout le monde
devant ses responsabilités ce que
j'entends depuis le début ce qu'il faut
faire plus et qu'il faut faire mieux
qu'ils et voilà mais quand on parle
quand on parle de ça à l'assemblée aux
vives ou dépenser trop donc il y a il
faut quand même être raisonnable on a
notre loterie aux nanos non mais c'est
toujours ailleurs qui vous est réservé
la fiscalité des cartes grises c'est
pour financer la mise à deux fois deux
voies des routes par exemple pourra
prendre un sujet polémique de la version
est fongible jeu vous pourrez vous parle
aussi des liaisons belfort-delle qui va
falloir faire ou quelles les ans
ferrovial ils ont ferroviaire et ainsi
de suite
au cdh en exhortant cette taille c'est
que le débat le mans trop c'est qu'on a
besoin de financement pour faire des
travaux en masse qui sont nécessaires
réclamé par la population et c'est le
choix budgétaires qui était le nôtre
cédric jeauneau sur ses priorités vous
parlez de l'infrastructure voilà donc
vous parler de financement monsieur menu
home est une des erreurs monumentales du
gouvernement a été de supprimer les
quotas et on le sait très bien l'air
cela aujourd'hui ces trois quarts de
poids lourds trois quarts de poids
lourds qui ne payent pour ainsi dire
aucunement l'infrastructure si ce n'est
par la taxe spéciale à l'essieu donc je
me pose des questions sur effectivement
le financement de cette route il ya un
réel besoin il ya un réel besoin
d'améliorer la sécurité sur cette route
sans un sou c'est difficile d'améliorer
à très court terme c'est trop tôt
toujours le problème de financement
on revient au car parce quand même on
n'a pas parlé dans la première partie de
cette émission de de cette nouvelle
fonction que porte le conseil régional
dont vous allez devoir organiser ce que
les conseils départementaux organise
actuellement c
réseau de bus vous allez tout unifié
comment ça va se passer
nous allons effectivement prendre des
compétences prévues par la loi et je les
dis puisque on veut un système unifié de
transport nous allons prendre la
compétence des cars départementaux des
cars scolaires sur la base actuelle avec
dégoût date que pour les janvier 2017
pour une cars départementaux 1er
septembre 2010 7 pour les transports
scolaires avec la possibilité
département par département d'accélérer
le processus
quand tu es département sont volontaires
le partenaire de questions michel deniau
sur la question des transports scolaires
c'est réglé avec les 8 départements et
deuxième question est ce que ce sera
gratuit comme vouziers suel engagé
pendant la campagne c'est les gens qui
reviennent c'est la loi c'est la loi qui
règle et les conditions du transfert
transferts de charges transferts de
recettes la loi et nous dialoguons avec
chaque département pour trouver le
meilleur tempo pour réaliser ce
transfert de compétences avec les agents
avec les agents vont être transférés
aussi les agences au transfert et donc
quand on dit vous n'allez pas la
compétence mais la compétence il ya les
élus qui décident mais la compétence est
léché des agents les agents seront
transférés nous proposons département de
lévis au début dans la localisation où
ils sont six dans chaque département il
nous envisageons aussi la possibilité
sur certains départements d'avoir un
maillage infra départementale
quand le siècle du département n'est pas
forcément bien localisé l'objet aux
vagues rendent en l'état si au moment du
transfert rien devait changer pour les
usagers et nous allons avoir des trajets
pour les usagers dans les six
départements où c'est gratuit ça reste
gravé dans les dorures non mais en
l'état
vous avez six des huit départements qui
ont des trajectoires différentes
quand on parle de gratuité c'est pas
pour tout le monde parce qu'une partie
des transports scolaires qui sont faits
par des agglos est où là cette payant
donc on a toutes les ce on a lui dû
territoire dit l'alimenter délivre un
but au début aux pros tels que c'est et
il y aura huit trajectoire
départementale pour qu'à terme non tail
hatem faire du mandat non dis-moi la loi
permet de faire ça sauf que c'est pas
acceptable aujourd'hui qui est des le
traitement en tout cas le service soit
pas rendu de la même manière en deux cas
pas avec le même coup c'est si c'est
gratuit pour certains usagers et encore
payant jusqu'à la fin du mandat pour
d'autres c'est pas toi quand vous avez
choisi dans des deux unifier les cartes
grises on vient d'en parler vous avez
choisi de le faire dès la première année
alors qu'on pouvait les talent est là
aussi sur le mandat je trouve que c'est
pas acceptable aujourd'hui de dire que
d'un côté quand ça nous arrange on va le
faire tout de suite puis quand ça nous
arrange pas on va étaler donc sur ce
point là non vous demandera en tout cas
d'assurer la gratuité tout de suite
monsieur monsieur madoff d'aller finir
monsieur et la question se pose que vous
essayez de nous gâter effectivement
c'est compliqué il ya plein de
situations je suis d'accord je connais
le sujet également
néanmoins la question des transports
scolaires elle se pose aussi il ya aussi
la question des transports interurbains
et dans ces transports interurbains
comment vous gérez demain des bus qui
vont faire des liaisons entre villes
dans un département avec un coût souvent
très modiques 1 1 euro 50 2 euros
poussant des départements et à côté de
ça début du début selon faire d'autres
liaisons via la sncf avec des prix on
l'a tout à l'heure beaucoup plus élevé
alors si vous voulez avoir une vraie
intermodalité si vous voulez avoir une
vraie mobile gestion globale de 2 des
transports il va falloir unifier les
transcender les coûts également si vous
nous annoncez que les anciens bucéphale
notamment chez moi en saône-et-loire
paso pris des buts sncf vous allez voir
c'est très compliqué à faire accepter de
l'année au dans la nièvre en suivant et
dans le territoire de belfort
chacun a son nom puisque va falloir en
effet ça aussi mais ses comptes alors
cette nouvelle compétence de la région
je comprends l'inquiétude des personnes
sur notamment sur le transport scolaire
et la gratuité c'est 150 mille enfants
tout à fait et je comprends l'inquiétude
parce que connaissant l'exécutif
socialiste
on n'est pas contre à voir maintenant le
transport scolaire payant dans tout le
le dpe tout le territoire de bourgogne
franche comté
on l'a vu ton là la hausse des cartes
grises ils ne vont pas hésité et je
comprends leur inquiétude
on s'y opposera comme lors des cartes
grises le front national était le seul
parti assiette vraiment opposés comment
voilà comment vous accueillez vous cette
régionalisation entre guillemets des des
services départementaux de la
régionalisation des transports sur
l'ensemble de la région bourgogne
franche comté peut être une bonne chose
à la condition qu'ils aient une
politique pragmatique homogène de la
fois sur les liaisons et une
complémentarité nous en avons déjà parlé
au début de ce débat mais également une
homogénéité sur les tarifications parler
des gratuités aujourd'hui alors ça va
peut-être vous étonner mais parler de
gratuité la fnaut qui n'est pas
forcément favorable
pourquoi parce que le transport un coup
finalement qu'il y ait des mesures
sociales pour les personnes qui ont vu
des faibles revenus c'est tout à fait
normal qu'il ait des gratuités pour ces
personnes c'est tout à fait normal
faisait partout dans toute la région que
cela doit se faire après bien évidemment
qu'il gratuité totale des transports
on doit à six départements sur huit qui
pratiquait la gratuité ou quasi en
france-comté ça reste une exception en
france risque y en a une petite dizaine
seulement en france deux départements
qui pratiquait la gratuité des
transports scolaires donc effectivement
campagnolo traduit clairement très
clairement il nous reste deux minutes
est ce qu on peut aussi imaginer que du
coup ça va un peu enlevé les frontières
puisque pour l'instant chacun s'occupait
de son département
est-ce que là il va y avoir des liaisons
entre les départements entre les villes
et départements notamment ray sur ingres
et besançon à gré dijon c'est toute la
desserte sur lequel nous sommes en train
de travailler avec la complémentarité
des mollahs farina faut faire vite mais
faut travailler faut dialoguer avec les
territoires
c'est la démarche que l'on engage et on
a le mandat
pour unifier tout cela alors je sais que
tout le monde pense qu'avec un coup de
baguette magique
y arriver ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est
pas réaliste parce que une période déjà
de prendre de responsabilités ya la
convention ter qui va être très
structurante pour cela parce que ce jour
ne l'a dit à juste titre ce qui reste
rupture ans qui est lourd ce qui est dur
à organiser ce qui est solide
c'est les dessertes ter et après il ya
tout ce qui ce faux tout est ce qu'il
faut tout celle des transports
départementaux les sous du ce les
transports à la demande dont nous
reprenons la compétence et c'est tout ce
que l'on devra innover sur les
territoires parce que ce que l'on veut
au terme de ce mandat c'est la volonté
d'avoir la mobilier des pour tous et
partout
nous avons heureusement du covoiturage
etc non mais vous avez le covoiturage
vous à l'auto est pas va être partagée
elle veut partager soit d'autopartage
soit en covoiturage parce que il ya une
problématique de développement durable
avec cela développement durable dans
tous ses aspects social économique et
efficacité n'est linéaire si on aura le
temps
l'occasion d'en reparler sans doute dans
cette émission et là on arrive déjà au
terme
alors merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci et si je vous rappelle
il ya sûr que vous pouvez revoir cette
émission sur nos sites internet dans un
instant le 12/13 se poursuit avec le
développement de l'actualité nationale
et internationale elle doit prier à tous
bon week-end à tous
mon